[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
four 800-835-6747 now here's your host
from amazing facts international
pastor doug batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear
an amazing fact engineers in the us
have created the world's most powerful
magnet
the magnet known as the central solenoid
was designed to make up the heart of the
world's largest fusion reactor
called the itter which stands for
international thermonuclear experimental
reactor
it's essentially a sun simulator using
the same process that powers the sun
to potentially offer nearly limitless
clean energy
when fully assembled in france the 000
ton
central solenoid magnet will be 59 feet
tall and 14 feet wide
and it'll be capable of producing a
magnetic field measuring
13 teslas that comes to about 280
000 times stronger than the earth's
magnetic field
making it strong enough to lift an
entire
100 000 ton aircraft carrier and that's
some magnet
friends you know the bible talks about
an even more powerful force
capable of lifting the whole human race
stay with us
we're going to learn more on this
edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
welcome listening friends if you've got
bible questions that's what this program
is all about we invite you to call in
with your bible questions we're going to
be with you for
the next hour and that number is 800 god
says
that's 800-463-7297
usually at the beginning of the program
we've got lots of room on the phone
lines so we invite you to give us a call
800-463-7
we're also streaming right now if you
want to see what's going on here in the
studio you can watch
and that would be on the amazing facts
facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page in
any event you tell your friends calling
we'd do our best to answer questions
about the bible
and living the christian life and my
name is doug batchelor my name is john
ross good evening friends and pastor
doug it's good to be able to do
bible answers live again we were out of
uh
out of town for a couple of weeks but
it's nice to be back and take bible
questions we are live as pastor doug
mentioned
and if you have a bible question we'd
love to hear from you pastor i opened
the program talking about a
very powerful magnet and of course we
use magnets
every day in everyday life it's got a
number of very practical and
and use uses uh that we use all the time
but to
build a magnet big enough you can just
imagine a magnet that could actually
lift
an aircraft carrier that's almost beyond
belief and yet they're trying to do that
i know that's the and i guess they've
they've got that
done this this uh sun generator
that they're building and they think
that it's going to be able to go online
by well initial testing 2025
they think by 2040 they're going to be
able to produce
fission nuclear energy
that is you know virtually free of any
outside
what do you call it resources and uh
it's a pretty
complicated science but this magnet
needs to be powerful enough
to hold these protons that are wanting
to explode in position it sounds pretty
scary actually
yeah lift up an aircraft carrier with a
magnet that's really something that's a
lot of power
makes me think about a bigger power you
read about in the bible
and jesus is speaking in john 12 32
and he said if i even i am lifted up
from the earth will draw all people
to myself and this he said signifying
what death he would die
through christ being lifted up on the
cross the love of god is demonstrated
and there is a drawing attraction
there's a power
that when people see the love of god the
bible says the goodness of god leads us
to repentance
and we love him because he first loved
us and it's seeing the love of god
that's where that drawing power comes
from that power of love
and they can lift the whole world out of
selfishness and sin
you know probably a number of our folks
are listening if they've you maybe heard
the phrase the power of the cross
well there is power in the cross it's
the power
in the demonstration of god's love for
fallen humanity
we have a book that talks about that
it's called the high cost of the cross
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls an asset free
if you're in north america all you have
to do is call the number 1-800-835
and ask for the book it's called the
high cost of the cross and we'll be
happy to get that in the mail and send
it to you
if you're listening outside of north
america you can go to the amazing facts
website just or dot amazingfacts.org.com
and you'll be able to read the book
right there online it's called the high
cost of the cross well passed it out
before we get to our
bible questions we always like to begin
with the word of prayer so let's go
ahead and do that now
dear father once again we are grateful
for this opportunity to open up your
word and study
you know the bible is your book it is
the most important book that we could
ever read and study
but we need the holy spirit to guide us
to lead us into a clear and full
understanding
of bible truth so bless our time
together be with those who are listening
we ask this in jesus name amen amen
well pastored the first caller that we
have is rick and he's listening in
canada rick welcome to the program
yes thank you good evening pastors how
are you
great and thanks for your patience hey
no problem no problem
um what i'm looking for tonight pastors
to get some clarification on genesis 9
3 where it speaks about every moving
thing
live shall be food for you i'm just
trying to get some clarification on that
versus genesis 1
29 as well as what's described in
leviticus
trying to get some clarification on what
what the intent of that
yeah well when you read in genesis 9 and
god tells noah after the flood
that you're free to eat of the moving
living creatures
up until the time of the flood the only
time they might have eaten
meat would have been for a sacrifice
because the sacrificial system was
established before
um the flood but people were largely
vegetarians you know god told
adam and eve and most of their posterity
was
probably eating a largely vegetarian
diet eating meat was a rare
exception but after the flood all the
vegetation is destroyed
and so god said well now you might eat
freely of the
foods but he specifies in genesis 7 2
what those animals are so if you read in
genesis 7 verse 2 he says you'll take
with you seven of every clean
animal male and female and then he says
of the animals that are
unclean so god has made a distinction
between the clean and the unclean so
what he says in genesis
chapter 9 verse 3 is following the
criteria
of genesis 7 of the clean animals you're
free to eat
he wasn't saying that man could now eat
buzzards and skunks and i mean
obviously there's some things that no
one would even think of eating
right exactly just looking for some
clarification some because some
individuals are taking that as in they
can eat anything that they wish
yeah well it's like mark twain said a
person convinced against their will
is of the same opinion still if some
people have their mind made up they want
to eat something
you can show them lots of scripture but
if they want to go by what the word of
god says it's pretty clear
that what you sow you're going to reap
and god does care that
our bodies are the temple of the holy
spirit
i couldn't agree with you more i thank
you for your time thanks for the
clarification have a good night
thank you rick appreciate your call you
know pastor dog we got a study guide
called god's free health plan and
actually talks about these verses that
um
was related to the question we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
an ass it's one of the amazing facts
study guide
lessons it's the number to call is
800-835-6747 and again the lesson is
called god's free health plan
i'm just actually looking at it right
now got it open on my computer just
a wealth of information from scripture
as well as things from science
and it's beautifully illustrated it is
yep if you have not yet seen the study
guide you need to call and ask again
it's 800-835-6747
ask for the amazing facts study guide
called god's free health plan
we've got dan listening in richland dan
welcome to the program
good afternoon uh hi uh
hi doug and yeah john ross hey i've got
a question about
uh handing out bible tracts um
i went to the pastor and asked him about
handing out some bible tracts
for sabbath and uh he said it thought it
would deter people
and ask me where in the bible does it
say hand out bible track
and i said well i said if you love me
ask do you love me feed my sheep so
is there anything is that is there any
restrictions on
how you spread the gospel well obviously
yeah that's a good question um you know
if you're looking for a verse that says
thou shalt hand out bible tracts keep in
mind
i think everyone knows that the printing
press wasn't really invented until 1500
years after
jesus by gutenberg and one of the first
books they printed on the printing press
was the bible
but the idea of sharing the gospel
and sharing information you know jesus
said go and teach all nations that's a
great commission
and if you can do it through word you
can do it through the written word
we're doing it right now through the
word on radio and television
and uh there's certainly nothing wrong
with that i mean god wants us to be
tactful
you know you don't want to accost people
and make and you know drive them away
but there's nothing wrong with
offering free literature to people if
they're open
you know revelation chapter 1 we find a
blessing on those who read
those who hear and then those who keep
the things that are written in the book
it's talking about the book of
revelation but also the bible as a whole
so right there in scripture we find a
great blessing for those who read and
hear and if that means sharing
literature so they can read they can
hear
well of course that's in harmony with
what the bible teaches now as pastor
mentioned
we need to we need to recognize usually
a good way to share literature is to
begin a conversation with somebody and
if they have an interest or they have a
question on something maybe they're
going through a crisis in their life
and you have an appropriate tract or a
little book that you can give them
that's a great way to share literature
with people you just want to
push stuff on them when they don't want
it yeah and amazing facts we've got a
whole lineup
of sharing literature called amazing
facts tracks
so we believe in giving out tracks a lot
of people order them from us
by the way there is a verse in second
timothy 4 13.
paul said to timothy and bring
the cloak i left at troas when you come
and the books
especially the parchments so they did
believe in
literature and paul told timothy's study
to show yourself approved
so they didn't read they did study and
they did
he said bring me a track and bring them
parchments
all right thanks you're cool dan we've
got sam you're listening in wisconsin
samuel welcome to the program
thank you brothers for taking my
question yeah
um i i i read uh in paul's letter to
timothy
requesting him to come to the church of
philippi in
chapter 2 verse 26 the name is mentioned
epiphates
as timothy's assistant can you mention a
comment on that individual aphrodites
yeah i think he's mentioned not only
in philippians chapter 2 verse 25 he's
also
mentioned in philippians
let me see that would be 4 18.
it says indeed i have all and abound and
i'm fully received
from aphrodite's the things that you
sent so
he had been sent from timothy to paul
who i think was in prison at this time
um and uh she said you know so
he's one of the christian one of the
believers and he's a close friend of
both paul and timothy and
and uh he was being used to communicate
messages and material between timothy
and paul yeah you know i'm just looking
at a little bit of a commentary on this
verse here on my computer and it says
that
he was um believed to be a minister
at uh colosses in asia minor so he had
uh some leadership
resolve position or responsibility in
the church
and so he knew paul and yeah
sounds like they had worked together and
instead in communication
yeah and he brought i think he brought
some kind of an offering to some support
to paul
and so it's like a sweet swelling
smelling aroma that usually means that
there's some kind of offering that was
given and the name
is greek and it's actually related to a
uh a greek
goddess so it's pretty clear that he was
probably not a jew he was a convert to
christianity he was a greek
well thank you appreciate your question
samuel i hope that helps a little bit
i don't think we've ever had that
question before yeah good one
yeah all right we've got jeff in montana
jeff welcome to the program
good evening evening i had a question
uh about predestination and if god knows
who will be saved and who will be lost
not saying that he decides that
but if he knows all things does the holy
spirit
still work on the hearts of those he
knows will be lost
and would that be casting pearls before
swine
okay good question well yes god does
know
all things but jesus i think
wants us to preach the gospel to the
whole world some will believe some won't
i believe the holy spirit strives with
every person
because god knows that there are some
people that
will ultimately not choose to follow him
i don't think that he's like a hospital
that does triage and they say
well that one's not going to make it so
don't waste any resources on them
you know what i mean like in an accident
so
god he pours all of his resources into
anybody that has potential
whether or not they're saved is usually
dependent on their choice
it says you know all that come unto me i
will receive
so because god knows it doesn't mean
that god is
participating in their being lost or
withholding his love from them
we have a verse in john chapter one
verse nine it's talking about christ but
it's also referring to the holy spirit
it says
that is the true light which gives light
to every man that cometh into the world
so the holy spirit is speaking to
everyone the gospel invitation has gone
to all
that's why jesus said whosoever
believeth
and he's baptized so it's for everyone
the invitations for everyone the holy
spirit will be speaking to everyone
god knows what they're going to do but
god gives everyone the same opportunity
yes and so yeah jeff that uh we do have
a book that talks about can a saved man
choose to be
lost it talks about predestination and
we can send you a free copy
the number to call for that is 800 835
the book again is called can a save the
man choose to be lost and of course this
is for anyone who would give us a call
800-835-6747
again if you're outside of north america
take a look at the amazing facts
website we've got deanna in
loma linda california deanna welcome to
the program
thank you um i have a friend here from
taiwan that's hoping you
gonna get some evangelistic meetings in
her country soon
i'd love to do it my question
is there's 12 gates mentioned
in heaven and whereas we enter after the
tribes of uh the sons of jacob
uh is there a reason that we have to go
in a certain one
you know i think you i think yeah good
question
when it talks in revelation pastor ross
may have the verse in revelation
22 chapter 21 talks about the new
jerusalem yes
and the 12 gates are there or i'm
looking at right here let me find it
so i god is not saying you have to go in
or out of a particular gate
i think the reason there's 12 gates is
because the lord
chose 12 apostles there's 12 tribes and
it's like there's these different
personalities and you know it seems like
god's church is made up of
all different people you've got andrew
who's very quiet and peter his brother
very loud
and it's like whoever you are you know
the high priest had 12 stones on his
breastplate they're all different stones
they're all precious stones
that's like god is saying i got a gate
for everybody you know i've made people
to be different
i'm not a cookie cutter god and um
so there's a gate for everybody yeah
it's actually an easy verse to remember
revelation 21 12 talks about 12 gates
so there it is talks about the 12 gates
into the new jerusalem two one one two
twelve years ago all right well hope
that helps deanna thanks for your call
good question we've got tammy listening
in virginia tammy welcome to the program
hello yes you're on the air
okay um i would like to know
some bible verses that tell me whether
women can be or not to be pastors of a
church
and is a judge like deborah in the bible
is she considered a leader such as a
pastor
and the same goes for mariam and the
other prophets
women yeah good question and i know it's
a it's a very sensitive question today
because of just uh it seems like there's
been a lot of
discussion on gender issues all over the
map
in the world today but i'm going to tell
you what the bible says
the bible tells us that men and women
are of equal value
when you read in galatians 2 28 the lord
says you know there's neither male or
female meaning that you know the
salvation availability and the
preciousness of every soul
god doesn't value jews more than
gentiles or men more than women
he values everybody the same but
obviously there are distinctions of
roles between men and women
uh you know women clearly have three
physiological functions that men do not
even have
so you know the role of women in
in families is going to be different in
the bible you see that the role of women
was different than the role of men you
do have women that served as prophetess
in the bible you've got hulda and miriam
and deborah and i mean technically mary
uttered a prophecy when she was called i
don't know that you'd call her a prophet
but
um but there's never an example in the
bible of women serving in the capacity
of apostle
pastor or priest those
roles that were you only have men doing
baptizing in the bible
when the kings that were chosen were all
men that god chose
so you do see a distinction in the rules
and i think that plays out in
the families the bible talks about the
relationship of
men should be the servant leaders in the
families that doesn't mean they should
be
despots or dictators but they should
lead the bible says husbands love your
wives
as christ loved the church and gave
himself for her
that's in ephesians chapter 5. so you
know paul also says that there's a
distinction
between the ministry of men and women in
the church and there's several verses so
probably the best thing would be to send
you we've got a booklet on that because
we get this question every now and then
it's a role of women in ministry god
calls
every believer to minister using their
gifts but there's a distinction in the
rules
and again we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747
the book is called god's role for woman
in ministry we'll send that to anyone in
north america if you're outside again
just go to the amazing facts website
tammy thank you for your call
we have got matthew listening in
mississippi matthew welcome to the
program
hello hello matthew you're doing good
and your question is just a blessing
blessing to have you guys
on air well thank you now you may want
to turn down your radio in the
background because you'll notice a delay
and it could confuse you
okay my question is uh
isaiah 65 20. it is speaking of
death in that verse and i have always
been
bewildered about that because this is in
uh
speaking of the new heaven and new earth
can you explain that for me
yeah and if you read in isaiah chapter
65 when you start with verse 17
it says behold i create a new heavens
and a new earth and the former will not
be remembered nor come into mind
uh so it's talking about you know
jerusalem is a joy
her people are rejoicing it says no
longer will weeping be heard well if
there's no weeping and there's no crying
and it says no more shall an infant from
there live but a few days they used to
have a high mortality of infants that's
verse 20.
nor an old man that is not fulfilled his
days for the child will die a hundred
years old
now that's a difficult translation the
word die there
in hebrew can also be translated cease
and it means that a child will not even
cease to be
a child until it's a hundred years old
because people are living forever if you
look in genesis you'll notice that some
of the
early patriarchs they didn't get married
until they were older than a hundred
and so it's basically saying in heaven
we're going to return to
god's plan where children grow up much
more slowly it says nor will there be
an old man that does not fulfill his
days you're not going to have people
young or old dying you read in
revelation there
is no more death there but a sinner
being 100 years old will be a curse
meaning that
the memory of the sinners are occurs
forever
even after 100 years right does that
help at all yes that helps i
i have always been bewildered by that
because i mean here i see the word die
speaking of death in the new heaven and
new earth and that just
does not add up with scripture yeah so
if you just
understand there in hebrew it says for
the child will
not even cease until it's 100 years old
a child shall cease 100 years old
meaning that'll cease to be a child
i mean you've never looked at someone 80
years old and say you're a kid
so it's telling us that people are going
to be living forever
right now yeah when you also you can
read in malachi chapter 4 speaking of
the new earth
it says that the um people will go forth
and grow
up so there are children in heaven
isaiah 11 says that i think it's isaiah
that the child will play on the whole of
the venomous serpent but it will not
hurt or destroy
so there are children in heaven but they
don't say children forever they're just
going to grow more slowly
because then you enter eternity as an
adult
all right well thank you matthew good
question we've got uh
shayla listening from rock hill south
carolina shayla welcome to the program
hello thank you for taking my call yes
um i'm calling um to find out and learn
more about salvation
i'm a little bit confused because
hebrews 10 and
26-27 says there will be no more
sacrifice but a certain fearful looking
for
judgment and in romans
9 18-23 it says god will have mercy on
whom and chooses
on whom he chooses and some of us are
made for destruction
if i'm seeking god and seeking salvation
out of fear of hell then that's not
genuine repentance is it
well it couldn't be a starting point you
know even john the baptist when he was
preaching he said
who has warned you to flee from the
wrath to come
and when god's angels led sodom let a
lot in his daughters
and wife out of sodom he said flee so
wanting to avoid uh hell can be a
starting point
but you want to get to the place where
you're not just running from something
but you're running to
jesus and so and by the way in hebrews
10 26 where it says for if we sin
willfully
that actually translates if we continue
to sin the word sin there is
it's talking about an ongoing if we
continue to persist in sinning willfully
we're not resisting we're not repenting
then there's no more sacrifice
but in romans when it tells us that you
know some are appointed to destruction
yeah god said he's appointed those who
resist his grace
to destruction but jesus said whosoever
will
let him come and you know christ says
come unto me all you who labor and are
heavy laden i will give you rest the
lord wants everybody to be saved
and that's including you and just the
context a little more than romans
chapter 9 if you read up a little
earlier starting verse 14 it's really
talking about nations it's not talking
about
individuals the point that was being
discussed by paul in romans was why was
israel chosen as
a nation through which god would would
work through the messiah who the messiah
would come
why not some other nation and paul is
making the point that god is the one who
chooses some nations
and chooses others and uh it's talking
about the nation of israel it's not
talking about individuals yeah because
everyone has the opportunity for
salvation he saw in the
with jacob and the israelites right
that's correct that's the context there
uh does that help uh shayla
um yes thank you you know we want to
encourage you as well i think you'd
really enjoy the book that we offered at
the beginning of the program called the
high cost of the cross
and it's talking about what jesus has
done for us and how we can have
salvation in him
we'll be happy to send that to you or
anyone who calls and asks the number
again is 800-835-6747 that's 800.
835 6747 ask for the book the high cost
of the cross
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks you know
pastor ross we have a couple of minutes
just before i should say a few seconds
before we're going to our mid
program break and i'd just like to
mention something that we'll be
mentioning along the way
amazing facts is having a big
evangelistic extravaganza
if i can use that term and it's going to
be october 15. it's called
panorama of prophecy any church in north
america can participate in this program
and we'll be giving you more details
along the way we've got a website called
panorama of prophecy
you're going to want to sign up your
church or your home group and
bring some souls to christ we're going
to be doing a full evangelistic program
october 15 november 13. we'll be right
back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
hello friends pastor doug batchelor here
with amazing facts
karine was divorced pregnant and very
concerned about her future
but god saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion
and he used a co-worker to share an
amazing facts
dvd that led karine to our website here
at the website she studied our
life-changing free online bible studies
what she learned there transformed her
heart
and today karine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today
and to make an eternal difference for
more people like kareem
your simple investment of faith and
amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with god's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others
know christ and the wonderful truth that
changes hearts
and it's easy to make a donation give us
a call at 877-506-1751
the number again 877-500
or just visit give.amazingfacts.org
or send your gift to p.o box 1058
roseville california 95678
you for studying the word of god with me
today and i hope that you'll plan now
to join me again next week as we
discover more amazing facts
from the word of god want to know god's
plan for our world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
bible study guides provide encouraging
bible-based answers to questions on
healthier relationships
when jesus will return and much more
prefer to watch while you read
our brand new prophecy encounters dvd
series makes the perfect companion set
order your study guides and dvds today
by visiting afbookstore.com or by
calling 800-538-7275
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7290
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
[Music]
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you've tuned in
somewhere along the way we are a live
international interactive bible study
you're invited to call in with your
bible questions any question about the
word of god
or living the christian life and we
don't have all the answers but we have
the word of god in front of us and we
will search together
to call in it's 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
also have another number that we share
during the program for
free resources we give away a lot of
free study resources
and we just send it to people well when
they ask
and we're also streaming on facebook as
well right now so if you want to
see what's happening here in the studio
you can see i've got the beginning of a
beard that'll probably shave off later
this week
not that interesting but anyway uh that
would be the amazing facts facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page and
i am doug batchelor
my name is john ross and we've got a
number of folks standing by
with their bible question we've got
angel listening in new york angel
welcome to the program
yes hi i have a question for you i know
it talks in the bible
of says uh enoch walked with god
he and it also says he didn't experience
death and he was taken
up to heaven like a rapture like to god
so why why is in the book of enoch in
the bible
all right that is a good question um the
only place you find
the book of enoch reference is in the
book of jude
there was a book called the book of
enoch jude does not say it was written
by enoch there the
the jews when they were in babylon they
had a book called the book of enoch and
had a lot of
very good spiritual information in it
but it wasn't really part of scripture
and it's not really endorsed as
scripture by other
bible authors but there's an excerpt
that jude quotes from that book was
probably written by the
during the babylonian captivities near
as the scholars can tell
and so that's why it's it was not
written by enoch because of course
enoch went to heaven and then there was
a big flood that washed everything away
he would have had to give it to noah who
would have had to give it to abraham and
so forth and somehow the book would have
survived
never mentioned by noah abraham moses no
one ever mentions the book of enoch
until you get to jude that's because it
and we have a copies of the book of
enoch today it's part of the jewish
literature but it appears during the
babylonian captivity
never mentioned before that does that
help angel
uh yeah it helps and i oh and someone
was telling me it also mentions
enoch mentions about christ i mean i
never read the book but
it'd be interesting to to see you know
what he says about
christ you know the coming of christ
yeah he may talk about the messiah he
doesn't
the book of enoch does not talk about
jesus specifically it does say the lord
is coming with ten thousand of his
saints
so that may be what they're talking
about and uh you know we know the
lord is jesus christ but i think enoch
just says the lord
yeah all right well thank you for your
call we have norman listening in indiana
norman welcome to the program
hello pastor roz and fox uh pastor
batchelor
yeah uh so uh thank you for taking my
question
and the question that i have is uh if
adam and eve were created
immortal and if so why was the tree of
life in the garden of eden
and taken away after they sinned well
where do you read that adam and eve were
made immortal i don't
i'm asking what that's good
the you know this is a common
misunderstanding immortality
is a gift and pastor ross said verse it
says god and god only have immortality
eternal life is given to the redeemed
adam and eve they had they were they had
eternal life on the condition they
continued to eat from this tree
they were not immortal only you know
only god half immortality the bible says
and
god is you know from everlasting
everlasting now god will give
immortality to those who patient
continuance and well-doing
and the bible says we seek after
immortality matter of fact that's one of
the verses
of pastor ross so um
there's several places in the new
testament where it tells us that
immortality is a gift given to the
redeemed
and you have some there yeah first
timothy chapter 1 verse 17 talks about
god who is immortal invisible wise
so one of the characteristics that's
clearly given to god
and first timothy 6 16 says god alone
has immortality
so that's first timothy 6 verse 16. so
yeah
god alone has immortality and then
there's a place also
and if you're doing a search on the word
where it says through patient
continuance we receive immortality
so it's something that we don't have by
birth adam and eve did not have by birth
that's why god said chase them out of
the garden if they don't eat from the
tree they'll die
obviously meant they're not immortal the
fruit would help perpetuate life
but um is that helping norm
absolutely yes thank you very much all
right you're welcome thank you so much
for your call
you're referring to romans chapter two
verse seven pastor talking about uh
patient
continuance in doing good that you might
receive immortality and that would be at
the second coming right
next quarter that we have is abigail
listening in california
mantega abigail welcome to the program
hello hi thanks for calling
and your question tonight um my question
is
um regarding deuteronomy chapter 24
verse 16
okay i'm in deuteronomy chapter 24. let
me read verse 16.
it says fathers shall not be put to
death for their children nor shall
children be put to death for
their fathers a person shall be put to
death for his own sins
and so what what's your specific
question about that verse
um because like several places in the
bible
when what like it has a thing where
when the father sins the whole family is
killed or like god tells
the people kill the whole family
yeah like in the story of aiken yeah
yeah so there are a few times uh once
with king
saul's sons david have had them slain
because the children were accomplices
in the crime now when it comes to aiken
aiken had stolen something from the city
of jericho when they conquered jericho
and he hid it in his tent and all of his
family knew he hid it in the tent
and even after joshua said they they
needed to confess whoever it was
the family they could have said you know
it was our father it was our grandfather
or our brother they didn't say anything
about it they kind of conspired they
were accessories to the crime
and so they were responsible because
they were supporting their father in
hiding this
in the tent under the carpet but
when a son is innocent i'll give you
another example
when one of the kings was assassinated
one of the kings of judah was killed by
his servants
well when his son began to reign he
killed the assassins
but he did not bother their families
because he said
the bible says the children shall not
suffer for the crimes of the parents
so and it also repeats that
in ezekiel 18 where it said
that the the parents will not be guilty
for the sins of this
children and the children will not be
guilty for the sins of the parents
the righteousness of the righteous will
be upon him and the wickedness of the
wicked will be upon
him and so does that answer
are there maybe a couple of other cases
you're thinking of abigail
um what about um exodus chapter 20 verse
5.
um the third and fourth generation of
those that hate me
yes like it for those who hate you
they'll like god will punish
for the um fourth and third generations
like
the children who of those people
okay that's good i'm glad you're asking
that because that was actually one of
the next ones i was thinking of did you
find the verse in ezekiel
um no i was actually looking up the one
with the third and fourth generation
numbers 14 18 ezekiel 34 7. yeah
and and it also tells us in the ten
commandments
it said when in the commandment about
idolatry it says
punishing wickedness unto the third and
fourth generation showing mercy unto
thousands of those that love me and keep
my commandments
you know there's a principle in the
bible where children often repeat the
behavior of the fathers
for three or four generations it takes a
while sometimes to get out of the cycle
and so when god says visiting the
iniquity of the fathers upon the
children
unto the third and fourth generation of
those that hate me
that means that the the parents that are
teaching the
idolatry to their families it takes
several generations for them to often
shake that
you know the word they used is iniquity
and it's kind of interesting it says
visiting the iniquity of the fathers and
the children
third and fourth generation the word
iniquity has has an interesting meaning
yeah it's connected to sin but even more
so
it's relating to selfishness or
rebellion
so the rep the rebellion of a parent is
often picked up by the children
and that can continue for three four
generations
they still guilty for their own sins but
they learn from their parents
and that's what god is warning again
saying be careful what you do is gonna
have an impact upon your children
yeah they they did a study for years
they had
an idea in the medical community they'd
say
well this this man is obese and his
children are obese and
probably he has an obese gene well they
they watched a little further and they'd
like have twins and one would be adopted
by another family and it wouldn't be
obese
what was happening is the eating habits
were being passed from the fathers
onto the children for third three and
four generations
and so that often happens with behaviors
absolutely yeah
so thank you very much abigail hope that
helps a little bit appreciate your call
we've got duncan listening in ohio
duncan welcome to the program
okay thank you thanks and your question
i duncan
why didn't destroy why didn't jesus
destroy
satan when he re rebelled
okay good question we know that god is
more powerful than the devil
so when the devil began to rebel against
god why didn't god just
send a lightning bolt out of his
fingertips and burn the devil up he
could have done that
because the devil had been telling the
other angels in heaven
that god is unfair and that god is a
tyrant and we don't need god's laws and
he doesn't let us have freedom
and he's a mean judge he still tells
people this all today
and jesus said no god is love if god had
burnt up the devil as soon as he began
to question god's goodness
all the other angels would have said uh
oh look what happened to lucifer maybe
he was right we better not
ever be questioning anything about god
or he's going to burn us up god does not
want us to obey him
because we're going to get beaten if we
disobey
he wants us to obey him because we love
him and because what he's asking is
reasonable
i've got several kids as does pastor
ross
and i want my kids to love me but i want
them to obey me i want them to obey me
because they trust me
and that my judgment has got their best
interest in mine i don't want them to
obey me every time i ask something
cowering and shaking that i'm going to
throw something at them or hit them
i want them to obey me because they
think father mother
loves me and they have what's in my best
interest
so if god had just killed lucifer all
the other angels their motive would have
changed
and uh so does that help a little bit
alex
it's time i don't get i'm sorry yes
it does all right well thank you very
much and we do have a lesson we can send
you an illustrated lesson on
did god make a devil the number to call
for that is 800-835-6747 and of course
this is available to anyone who calls
and asks just ask for the study guide
it's called
dead god create a devil and we've been
talking about the study guide passed
today throughout the program
we want our listeners to know you can
call that number
to them you'd 800-835-6747 to sign up
for the free amazing facts
bible study course and we'll actually
send it to you in the mail
absolutely free and we'll cover all of
these different bible truths that we
find
and it's free so yeah take advantage of
it online it is available online as well
just going to the amazing facts website
and you can sign up for free there as
well we got clement listening in
ohio clement welcome to the program uh
yeah
thank you can you hear me we can uh yeah
and i had a question from um
matthew uh 24 36 it says
but of that day and hour knows no man
no not the angels of heaven but my
father only so my question was that
if jesus said that only god knows and if
jesus knows everything
does that mean jesus also knows when god
is coming or
is it just god the father i think when
jesus
made that statement in matthew 24 he
said the only one who knows that
is the father christ when he was on
earth as a man
he did not have all the knowledge of the
cosmos swirling around in his mind
and so jesus obviously now
knows the day and the hour of his coming
uh god the father i mean i just cannot
picture that jesus is up in heaven and
saying oh father please tell me
when am i supposed to come back he's all
i can't tell you it's a secret
uh you know because jesus is he is god
also and so he knows now but as a man
he didn't know everything and um he had
laid aside his divinity
so does that make sense
yeah yeah he christ doesn't want anyone
picking a date for his return he said we
should be ready all the time it's going
to happen and such an hour as you think
not
and there are signs we can look at he
said that they should not overtake you
as a thief
so you know we should be watching and
looking at the signs
you know we have a study guide talking
about the second coming of christ it's
called
ultimate deliverance and we'll be happy
to send that out to anyone who calls and
asks the number is 800-835-6747
you can ask for the study guide called
ultimate deliverance and will give you
all the bible verses connected with the
second coming of christ
we got uh demarcus listening in georgia
demarcus welcome to the program
hey guys how's it going we're doing well
how are you doing can you hear me yep
i'm doing good i'm doing good
uh this uh question is uh
basically uh more of a personal question
as far as your uh walk with uh
christ i have just recently been
introduced to the sabbath
the sabbath truth and just to me
it's like one of the deepest things you
know in the bible
and when i try to tell people about it
from my old church or just people on the
job
they they're not sure about it and i'm
like i feel like
they should be more alarmed i mean dates
have been changed
and you know people are just
not challenged about it how do you guys
handle that well i went through the same
thing
you know when i first became a christian
i i didn't know initially about the
a number of things i didn't realize that
you know some of the ten commandments
had been ignored by the church
and you know there's one church that
kind of ignores the commandment about
idolatry and they got
idols everywhere and people pray to them
well that's one of the ten commandments
you don't do that
and then there's another commandment and
we've got to remember these are not ten
suggestions these are commandments that
god spoke from the mountain
this is you know the law of god and uh
he says he's commanded us to rest
every seventh day to gather together to
worship him and
and uh you know a lot of christians
shrug and say oh it doesn't matter when
i whenever i'm ready or
whether i keep the day or not or they
don't believe it's important to keep it
holy
god says keep it holy and it's one of
his commandments
and breaking god's commandments is
called sin you're right it's a big issue
but
so much of the christian world looks
around and they say well no one else
seems to be too excited about it so it
must not be a big issue
but it's like back in christ's time
some of the people said well if he was
really the messiah the religious leaders
would be more excited and they're not
very excited so maybe he's not the
messiah
and so it's you know kind of the um the
herd mentality
with some of these things is what you're
probably running into
does that make sense in demarcus yes yes
it does
it does but don't lose your enthusiasm
you know and
you can't force you know you can't go
beat people over the head with the bible
and say
didn't you know this but you know when
you get an opportunity you pray for
grace and wisdom and
and people are going to be interested in
the truth hopefully
okay that's why we do this program thank
you
all right thanks so much next quarter
that we have is nina listening in puerto
rico nina welcome to the program
hi thank you and thank you for taking my
call
what part of puerto rico are you in i'm
in fajardo
okay yeah which is the north east
corner we were in ponce a couple of
years ago doing some meetings and i'd
love to go back sometime
but anyway so your question um i had
heard uh
something about multiplication christ
and i want a little bit of clarification
on that if you can help me with that
yeah good good question melchizedek
is a type of christ now there was a real
person in the bible during the time of
abraham
he was a high priest and he was also the
king
of an area that they called salem later
that
hamlet that small village of salem
became the city
of jerusalem the word jeru means city of
and so melchizedek when
abraham came back from fighting this
battle with these kings in the north
he was victorious and he gave a tithe of
all that he had to melchizedek well
mckinsey
dick the king and the word melchizedek
means king of righteousness
of salem he brought out bread and wine
and when you get to the new testament
and i know pastor ross have probably
done several sermons on this in hebrews
melchizedek is identified as a type of
christ
christ is the king of the new jerusalem
he gave us the new covenant in the bread
and the grape juice
he is the king of righteousness and so
there were some parallels
and if you read about it's actually in
hebrews chapter seven almost the entire
chapter is a parallel between
melchizedek the historical individual
and how he foreshadows or is the type of
christ
what is interesting pastor doug is that
you have mercy who
is a king of a place called salem
eventually it becomes jerusalem
he's a king but he's also a priest and
of course jesus
is both king as well as priest and
abraham gave a tithe to melchizedek
recognizing
his importance and his responsibility
and so christ receives our praise he
receives our
service and so there's all kinds of
wonderful parallels between melchizedek
and and christ but christ was not
melchizedek he was a real person
right exactly hey thank you i hope that
helps a little bit
nina and uh appreciate your call we're
going to try and get a couple more in
here
we've got roger listening in tennessee
roger welcome to the program
roger you might have your mute on
sometimes people patiently wait and they
mute their phones
they're there roger yes okay thank you
thank you and thank you so much for
taking my call yeah uh my my question is
this
uh is it possible for someone that has
been born again as jesus told us we had
to be and he told nicodemus he the
negative is that you must be going in
my question is this someone that has
been born again is it possible that
individual to lose their salvation
after being more have truly been born
again and except in christ as their lord
and savior
yes i i think that you if you look at
some scriptures
uh for example in revelation pastor ross
jesus gives a warning to the church
and he's talking this is the church
these are believers and he says unless
you repent
your candlestick will be taken out of
its place
and you have examples in the bible of
people who were prophets like
balaam he was a prophet of god obviously
called filled with the spirit
but he grieved away the holy spirit and
he died a lost man
and then you have examples of people
like king saul
who god called to be king he filled him
with the holy spirit
but over the years saul became careless
and eventually proud and finally he was
demon-possessed
and he went to a witch and died by
suicide and we don't expect to see saul
in the kingdom so you know that that
doesn't mean we can't have assurance of
salvation
but i think we need to be very careful
about saying well i i accepted jesus i
know i was born again
so now i can live for the devil and i
can i can continue in sin
uh you know hebrews 10 26 says if we
continue to sin willfully
after we've received a knowledge of the
truth
then there's no more sacrifice for sin
and jesus said in matthew
24 13 and it's mentioned in also mark
he says he that endures to the end the
same shall be saved so being a christian
requires
endurance we need to abide in christ we
need to come to him daily
so it's not a one time experience to
abide in christ is the day by day
experience paul said i die daily
jesus says take up your cross daily paul
said i have to be on my guard
while otherwise while i preach to others
i become a castaway
and so even paul recognized that his
salvation was something to
nurture so a lot of christians think
once i'm saved i can be careless about
my relationship with the lord i can't be
lost and
that i think is a very deadly uh
misunderstanding
you know we got a book it's called can a
saved man choose to be lost and it's
this very subject that we'll
talk about in the book if you'd like
receive it the number is
saved 800-835-6747 choose to be lost
thank you roger
yeah thank you we've got jeff listening
in georgia jeff welcome to the program
thank you actually i was in georgia but
i'm driving a truck
heading north and i'm in south carolina
now you waited all the way from georgia
to south carolina well thanks for your
patience
yeah you guys uh your program is uh one
of the most useful programs i've ever
heard on christian radio
uh thank you that's a great compliment
it and i appreciate your what you do uh
i keep losing your signal though
because i keep driving i keep moving you
know yeah
my question is about the tower of babel
i don't know where to find it in the
bible and the lesson about it
and i was hoping you could give me a
quick synopsis of
why and what i'm supposed to gain from
you know what what am i supposed to
learn from the tower of babel
all right very good that's genesis
chapter 11 and this is shortly after the
time of noah when people began to
multiply and spread
over the face of the earth and some of
them
were afraid for one thing they're hoping
that god would not send another flood
they said you know let's build a tower
and you know in case there's a flood
we'll have this high point we can run to
it'll reach into the heavens so it's
tower babel sort of represents man's
efforts to save himself
it also represents rebellion they said
let's make a tower to make a name for
ourselves they're not interested in
making a name for god they're making a
name for themselves
and furthermore they want to make this
tower so that they won't scatter across
the face of the earth god said go
forth fill the earth be fruitful well
instead they're conglomerating in one
spot
god said you're disobeying me on several
counts here
and so and the king was we think that
nimrod
was uh he's a mighty hunter against god
that's why i think the original puts it
and so god says look i'm going to i'm
going to
confound i'm going to confuse i'm going
to disrupt your project down there i'm
not going to bless it
and the way he did it was where everyone
spoke one language
all of a sudden their languages all got
confounded and confused and there was
just small groups that seemed to
understand each other
they stuck together and everybody else
sort of just fragmented the building
project
fell apart and strife and they began to
scatter around the world
so it's telling us trust that we cannot
save ourselves
salvation comes through god that we need
to obey god's word and don't live to
make a name for ourselves we want to be
making a name for god
so a lot to learn from by the way you
get to revelation talks about babylon
too
and babylon ended up becoming a city
that was in opposition to
the new jerusalem well listening friends
it
would not be fair and we see that uh
kavoy and marlon and deborah
and excellence we didn't get your calls
tonight we hope you give us a chance
next week
don't forget that we're going to be
having a big evangelistic program you
can participate in
in your church or your home group and
that'll be
october 15 the panorama of prophecy
thank you so much for keeping amazing
facts on the air if you want to support
us
it's all paid for by you
amazingfacts.org
we'll study again next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control
or perhaps new life challenges are
frightening you more than they should
are you sinking while you're thinking
excessive worry can consume you
eating you from the inside out resulting
in sickness
insomnia and paralyzing fear it can also
damage relationships ruin opportunities
and yes diminish your witness for the
gospel
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious
i'd like to recommend for you my new
book finding peace in a world of worry
you'll discover a lifeline to victory a
place where you can
cast your cares upon christ and
experience a serenity
that isn't subject to your circumstances
get your copy of pastor doug's
finding peace in a world of worry today
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
deep within the pages of the bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds
great love and great sacrifice
but behind them is another hero
hidden in plain sight amid the shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the
entire bible tapestry
shadows of light seeing jesus
in all the bible get your copy today
by calling 800 538
or visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
sign up for our free bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions